all right what's going on guys this is
rob and after the season finale
of the mandalorian right which was
amazing i have been jonesing for star
wars and here's a funny thing i've kind
of really been wanting to cover star
wars for a while now right like
especially the mandalorian wars i really
feel like we should cover that
technically it's there's not really like
a mandalorian wars comic series right
like it's covered in essentially the old
republic comics but it's more of like a
background event
but if anybody has any particular comics
that like point directly in you know to
like the mandalorians like anybody know
anything about the mandalorian comics
send them to me like post them in the
comments and like i will cover it
because dude the man
do i love the idea the mandalorians
they're like basically the star wars
version of like spartans
from like ancient greece right greek
spartans so i'm i'm covering
what's probably the coolest moment ever
in darth vader where he faces off
against
like 150 like rebels right like like
rebel soldiers whatever you want to call
them rebel volunteers the events of this
particular story vader down this takes
place
in the aftermath of a new hope right so
like the destruction of the first death
star
and as you guys know from seeing like a
new hope that when luke skywalker showed
up on the scene vader was like dude okay
so like this guy this guy's got the
force with him and like started
realizing okay there's something about
this kid
and all that kind of stuff and of course
we know that it's not until empire
strikes back that vader confronted luke
skywalker
with the revelation that darth vader was
luke skywalker's dad right and so
because of that vader's on the hunt for
luke skywalker right he's on the hunt
for this kid
trying to find him now darth vader is
traveling to this planet called rogus
voss which is
as far as he's aware the last known
location of where luke skywalker was and
this information comes by way of a woman
named dr aphra now dr aphra is a really
really cool character she's basically
like the star wars version of indiana
jones like
her comic stories are amazing it's so
cool and essentially what had happened
was that she was kind of greeted by
darth vader and then she was offered to
join darth vader's side you know for
particular cause a mission that he was
going on the funny thing about this is
that she's got two droids uh one is
called bt1
and the other one is triple zero they're
like murderous versions of c-3po and
r2d2 is effectively what they are
they're hilarious their droids are
amazing
in the end he's given this information
this is where we believe luke
skywalker's at as far as we're aware
it's a dead world you
should be able to track him down pretty
quickly grab the kid and then bring him
to the service of the emperor right
because as we know
at this point in the story in terms of
luke skywalker's history he's nowhere
near capable of going toe-to-toe with
darth vader right it's not until he gets
to dagobah during empire strikes back
that he actually starts to get to the
point where he could basically present
himself as any measure of a challenge to
vader because of that as soon as vader
comes out of hyper speed he arrives at
edva's voss
and is immediately met with like 36
x-wings that were not supposed to be
there right the information that they
had was like there was nobody there
there's nothing there now these guys are
here and you could call it luck of the
draw but does luck really have anything
to do with it
like when you end up confronting darth
vader like it's bad luck of the draw
right like they're literally just on
like
some regular routine missions right just
kind of doing their thing going on
drills
effectively right and they're just kind
of canvassing the area making sure that
nobody's supposed to be there who's not
supposed to be there and as soon as they
see a tie fighter they don't know that
it's darth vader man let me tell you
something right what you are about to
see here
is quite possibly one of the most
spectacular ass whoopings in the history
of star wars right they immediately jam
the frequencies of this guy and it's
like okay whoever this tie fighter is we
don't know how he got here he's way too
far to be out here by himself right so
there's probably a fleet somewhere
around here somewhere
jam is communication so we can't go back
and report to anybody because we're
rebels right we're literally a militia
force running on a shoestring budget so
like they immediately jammed the
communications of vader but because of
the fact that the communications start
getting disrupted
vader's initial thought is that it was
probably it was possibly a trap set up
by aphra and goes as far as to tell her
like if this is a trap
you would better hope it kills me
because if i find out that you set this
trap up i'm gonna come back and there's
nowhere in the galaxy you can hide right
like there's
nowhere you can go i will find you and i
will make you beg for death right which
is exactly what he would do and so she's
like no
i'm not that crazy right like there's no
circumstance where i would like
screw you over like that right like i
know who you are i know what you're
capable of and so it's one of these
things
where vader basically picks up on the
idea he begins to sense luke skywalker
through the force that he is actually on
this planet and so initially like she
she tells him like you have to run and
he's like i'm the lord of the sith so
darth vader's like i'm not running
anywhere right they're the ones who
should be running now for all these
rebels here in these x-wings as far as
they're aware it's your
standard imperial pilot flying some tie
fighter this this guy is
like it's it's literally a cakewalk to
destroy you know a rebel pilot i'm sorry
a an imperial pilot in a tie fighter
with all these guys here
but here's the thing man this is vader
right like one of the like probably the
single greatest pilot in the entirety of
the galaxy right this guy comes
flying right through as soon as these
x-wings open fire he's like he's behind
him before they even knew what happened
and just starts ripping them apart right
i mean just dude just starts crushing
these guys right just obliterating them
from every direction they have no idea
what's coming right like as soon as they
turn around he's already on the
offensive coming right back at him again
and they're like all units attack right
and like they start to get pissed off
because they're like who in the hell is
flying this thing is one of them is like
a dead man it's darth vader's son so
like as soon as they start start
attacking him because of the fact that
he's got deflector shields right he's
able to effectively deflect pretty much
all the shots they fire on him and he
just starts
picking them apart piece by piece this
is insane
this is probably the most spectacular
ass flipping ever in the history of star
wars not even in hell would you see a
massacre like this right like these guys
are getting obliterated and the funny
thing about it is they never even had a
chance
these guys started locking on torpedoes
to destroy the destroy the tie fighter
and darth vader just like reaches out
with the force and sends the torpedoes
off in all these different directions
and just keeps on coming right just
keeps on ripping these guys up now while
that's going on
luke skywalker is part of part of of red
group right you guys know that from from
episode four
luke skywalker's out there watching all
this happen right and he's just like
okay
that's darth vader and they're they're
like wait a minute like are you talking
about like the darth vader it's like do
you know of another darth vader
what other darth vader in this galaxy
are you aware of who flies a tie fighter
it's insane right it's kind of okay so
like as soon as he's like it's vader
right they're just kind of well doesn't
really matter who it is like we're gonna
take him out and it's like no you can't
right like
like vader is ridiculously capable he's
got the power of the force
we can't defeat him like this right we
can't go flying in with x-wings and
destroy vader because you'll kill us all
so luke skywalker like literally just
like like does this kamikaze run right
it's the craziest thing and he has this
plan right he's banking on this idea he
goes flying in towards darth vader and
he just kind of
lets you know he basically tells like r2
like close combs right
shut off communications and it's like
okay and so darth vader sees luke
skywalker initially and doesn't realize
it's him and thinks he's just like some
crazy guy who wants to go toe-to-toe
with vader right he's just kind of like
a worthy opponent cool and then
immediately he senses the fact that it's
luke and he's like holy cow
so luke basically uses the connection
between vader and himself through the
force to momentarily distract him crash
his head long into darth vader and sends
him flying down into the world right now
luke skywalker goes crashing down too
and the initial fear is that luke
skywalker died right like the other
rebels are basically afraid that luke
skywalker could have possibly died here
the other part of this is that vader
realizing it's luke kind of makes his
off-hand a remark
if he is truly strong in the force this
will not end him now remember this is
kind of a tenet
of the sith right the idea that only the
strong deserve to survive right like the
rule of two that you have a master and
you have an apprentice when the
apprentice becomes strong enough to kill
the master he kills the master and then
takes an apprentice of his own it's been
that way for a long long time
it's the nature of the sith that only
the strong deserve to survive because if
the race is going to survive
it needs to be led by the strongest
people right so not an unreasonable
philosophy
but both vessels basically go crashing
down you know on the under the surface
of the planet and as soon as that
happens
right they're kind of like okay
obviously vader's not going to die in a
crash right like
that's never going to happen so like
okay let's get out there and let's get
vader they end up bringing in like y
wings right like they're they're rebel
bombers
right they send out like a battalion of
people and then you switch over to
princess leia and han solo who is kind
of like out there now remember han solo
did come back at the end of a new hope
and like rescue luke but he's still kind
of in that position where he's he's
basically like okay i'm on the side of
the rebels but i still don't really know
if i believe in the force yet
but i'm still trying to bang leia so
like i'm gonna hang around a little
while to see if like i can get her
between the sheets you know and then
like if i can
cool then i'll hang around a lot longer
as we know he did right he got laid
between the shoes multiple times so like
we know that happened right and so
at this point when he's talking to her
she's kind of like okay vader's on
is on vargas right like he's on this
planet right vargas boss and it's kind
of like okay
initially han solo's like you guys are
going to go after him because leia's
like we got to send a whole battalion to
people right like we got to send all the
rebels that we have there
we're sending directly to go confront
darth vader and she's like then we also
have general dadana who's basically
sending an entire battalion to back them
up
right so she's like we're just throwing
sheer numbers at vader hoping that we
can turn it into a battle of attrition
and effectively wear him down right to
the point that we can
essentially overtake him because when
you're the rebels and you're talking
about
a sheer force of nature like darth vader
that's really all you can hope for
is a battle of attrition right just
wearing him down just throwing just huge
amounts of numbers of people at him to
the point that he can't overcome
everybody right and that's kind of
what's what they're what they're
shooting for now for the most part leigh
is like okay i'm gonna go out there and
han solo's like then you're not going
out there alone right i think that what
you're doing is stupid
but like if that's where luke is i'm not
letting you go out there by yourself so
again this kind of feeds into the notion
of han solo caring about more than
himself and going in the direction of
being someone that fights for a greater
cause than his own individual interest
at that particular point in time right
kind of the shift of han solo from
becoming a scoundrel in every sense of
the word both in character development
as well as
kind of how he sees the world moving
into a traditional hero right right and
so because of that you know he hits up
chewbacca basically says okay we're
traveling
to vogue's foss it's gonna be a stupid
decision like we're literally gonna go
against what is in effect the current
lord of the sith outside of the emperor
right so like darth vader the second in
command
we're gonna go fight a man i don't you
know i'm basically doing it for v for
for leia you know so like i can i can
rescue luke and kind of continue being a
hero
that kind of a thing but like they're
basically going on this mission and so
it's like okay right as soon as the
rebel fleet goes launching out in that
direction
we switch back over to darth vader on
this planet and as he's here and he
begins to emerge the y-wing starts
showing up and the initial thought is
there's no sign of vader he may have
died in the crash but then they realize
he's alive right they get visual
confirmation they see him there and
vader's just standing there and like as
they come running in with their y wings
and launching a bombing run
darth vader literally uses the force and
like picks up these huge chunks of rocks
and just throws them into the ship right
and just just like sends these y wings
crashing
crashing into each other and like
crashing into the ground like that right
in the span of like one move he took out
all these y wings
and that's the end of it now for luke
skywalker himself he of course
survived the the entire ordeal along
with r2d2 at this point it's just making
his way back to
the rest of the group right now this is
probably the single best moment in the
entirety of the story right
it's ridiculously good so it's vader is
making his way there and
making his way to where he believes luke
skywalker should be or at least using
the force to sense luke's location and
traveling to where he's at he's suddenly
kind of ambushed by all these rebels and
it's kind of interesting because vader
kind of looks around and he says okay
so this place is is is powerful in the
force right it's not the most powerful
place ever it's not the most powerful
forced planet ever but there is forced
power here this was once the side of a
jedi temple it makes sense that luke
would lead the rebellion here right or
the rebellion would be drawn to this
location since they are more or less
whether they know it or not
tied to the light side of the force but
then suddenly as he's ambushed all these
rebels are just like
like darth vader lay down your weapons
you're completely surrounded with the
most
beast response ever with the most beast
dude
man let me tell you something the most
beast response ever darth vader looks at
them all and says
all i'm surrounded by is fear and
dead men with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here to comments explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like
and i will catch you all later
[Music]
peace
[Music]
so
[Music]
you